what are your kids into these days well
they definitely have gone through a
phase where they have been asking me
about as they would say se X are you
doing this because Andy's here and you
don't think he can spell are you guys
talking about hockey
yeah all right yes Andy they really are
they're interested in that and they want
to know well my older daughter yes and
well she started being interested in a
few years ago she's ten now so around
six she so I had to come up with
something when she would say what is sex
mm-hmm and mm-hmm I didn't know what to
do so I just said it's a special hug
kind of is I suppose many did you say
well I don't say anything because I
can't because my wife instantly tells
them everything oh yes my wife is one of
those you know very progressive she's
just well I'll tell you you know and
then chill and I'm I I there's no time
for me to say anything because she jumps
right in she's dying for them to ask
because she has drawings and maps and 3d
models I want to talk about like oh
there's a magical patch somewhere a
cabbage patch and you know I thought I
was going to be like that and and
definitely pride myself for better or
worse I'm being really a big talker and
really open with them and aggressive and
yeah yeah hippie dippie let's get in
there and talk about it and you know
especially with girls you know really
open with the discussion of anatomy and
everything but then suddenly when she
actually asked me what happens I was
like it's a special hug yeah and that's
about it yeah and lo and behold you
arrived yeah anyway yeah I figured first
of all I'm totally fine with what you
told her I think I think special hug is
fine since then we've had to elaborate
so it's become a problem then she asked
me what safe sex was
which will say I know what making sex is
and making sex I love that she says and
she'll said she heard it for at school
or something that she heard something or
she's just so excited wait a minute how
do you explain safe sex if you've told
them it's a hug you don't tell them
there's a like a condom that surrounds
an entire body with mittens on it and
you that's how you hug I think I might
have left the room right check something
yeah I mean it's just yeah it's hard
yeah I can imagine if your wife could
come over and just oh my god my wife it
would take her five minutes to just bust
in the door and be like here we go and
then you know they'd be traumatized
everyone would be traumatized I'm
traumatized I didn't know how it worked
for my wedding night I was like it's
time for a special hug
nursing my god what are you doing
that looks really special yeah
you